foreign
[Music]
thank you
what's going on guys
it's added we're coming at you with
another
attic show we talk about the past
present and future gaming I'm definitely
a little behind on everything right now
I'm still recovering from
playing a raid the other night all night
I ain't doing that ever again it's
completely messed up my sleeping
schedule I feel like I'm tired 24 7
right now
but anyway the show must go on but I got
my co-host with me Dirk Gregory what's
going on
Ellie what is up my man playing raid you
know I'm doing that raid all night mess
your sleep schedule up huh yeah pretty
bad
yeah I got a water though
there you go
yeah man um
I'm happy to be here man let's let's
let's have a good time talking about
whatever is going on whatever you want
to talk about my man yeah it's been kind
of a little dry this week
unless we want to talk about ABK
oh yeah
if you want to talk about APK there's
plenty to talk about but
we really don't want to talk about APK
do we
don't matter to me
[Laughter]
but you know there's I I got some stuff
to talk about man I found a little bit
apparently there's a uh there's a
trademark placed on um new to
Castlevania oh yeah I heard I heard
about the ghost wire officially getting
announced for Xbox yep April 12th no
that's a game I'm gonna avoid at all
cost
s oh why is that because it's first
person I don't know like I saw the game
and it just didn't appeal to me like I
don't know like yeah but you know I like
I like um Tango game works so I'm
definitely gonna check it out
yeah I think uh they're a talented
Studio especially you see something like
um you know Hi-Fi rush but when I saw
that game it just it didn't really like
click like I didn't even play that on
Playstation because most of the time I
play all of the games on whatever
platform but yeah I avoided that game I
was like that game it don't look it
don't look good to me
that's one of the benefits of Xbox game
pass I'm going to download it give it a
try if I don't like it I honestly like I
I did with pentiment
I played before I didn't really like it
I might give it a try again eventually
but just uninstall it you know you know
there's actually people out there
that think you should have to pay for a
game to actually give your opinion on
something
really
so you said not playing the game just
pay for it yeah because they feel like
if you don't pay for it like
you you won't really try to give a game
a chance because you're you're not
financially like backing that like it
doesn't have anything to do with
finances and let me guess it was a
PlayStation framework that said that to
you
I've seen a lot of them actually and
yeah a lot of them is PlayStation fans
that explains everything yeah because to
me I can understand that mentality a
little bit but it just falls short to me
because it's like
I don't get how you have to pay for
something to give your honest opinion
you know I I could see more people like
getting behind Okay how can you
realistically review something when
someone sends it to you for free
I could I could understand that argument
better and I don't even really
understand that argument because I do
feel like this is the only industry
that you get Shane for getting free
stuff
that's what it seems like
um
listen man
the new narratives that was that has
been created
this generation alone is is absolutely
ridiculous man some of this stuff I just
can't believe some of this stuff we
would not say or do in real life
but yet instill in this community we
will hear stuff like this if someone
takes you out to dinner to their
favorite restaurant and say attic man
you gotta try this this restaurant
Burger I will buy it for you
so
with these guys logic if this person
buys you a burger from their favorite
restaurant
you can't reveal because you didn't buy
it no that's stupid man that's stupid
yeah I feel like people people take this
stuff way too seriously yeah it's crazy
bro
so what are you looking forward to about
ghostwire
um why you know the game looks
interesting to me I do like horror games
at this point in my life I actually
enjoy her horror games more than I ever
have
um like I said I love uh The Evil Within
franchise and it's a new IP from that
studio so I'm definitely interested
um plus I'm a bot in this first party to
be honest with you
no but you know I really just want to
play it
you'll probably enjoy it
I think I will and I like first first
person games so yeah I think I will if
if Microsoft was smart they'd make a
death loot tube and a Coast Wire too
just be like
you you guys got the original but you
don't get the sequel you know because
right
and you know just a little Jive for a
little bit payback on that um
time exclusivity huh not even time to
exclusivity like octopi traveler too
I got you how we get the original they
don't get the original
but we don't get the sequel right and
which and they don't own Square Enix I
could see if they own Square Enix or
whoever developed the game I don't know
who developed the game
um but you know we're going to talk
about Square Enix here like later you
know we're going to talk about score
Enix and their nfts
and uh you know Xbox in 2023 and what
kind of solid year um
we expect from them for this but like I
said
thanks thank you guys for coming to the
attic show we talked about the past
present future gaming
um you know we're gonna go ahead and get
this show on the road now let me go
ahead and switch over
to start working on these time stamps
because you guys know how they'll come
after me they're coming in the chat
they'll be like addict why ain't you
doing time stamps while I'm doing time
since first time step is 10 minutes and
10 seconds there you go timestamp I'm
off here
new Castlevania
dirt apparently there was a trademark
place for cash
Castlevania by Konami
now
first of all how do you feel about the
Castlevania like franchise are you a fan
or are you just like it is it is what it
is
more of a it is what it is kind of guy
with Castlevania um I Won't Say I'm a
huge fan never finished any of the games
I definitely played a few
um
I Won't Say I'm a huge fan it's just
kind of like yeah you know this that'll
be a cool game if it's I could see a new
style Castlevania being pretty good I
remember that one they made for the 360.
what was the name of that 360 in the PS3
it was kind of like God of War kind of I
can't think of the name of it no that
one was pretty decent um but Curse of
Darkness baby I don't remember what it
was called there's somebody in the chat
Hill there's a remake of well yeah I
remember it didn't follow the original
one
I don't know no no it I don't believe it
was a remake I don't um
of the castle of any games
that's the name of it yup I didn't
finish that one but that one was pretty
decent um so it's kind of like
I you know I always love to see new
games come out and I believe that
franchise is you know it's a big
franchise so I'm definitely interested
to see whatever they're gonna do but do
you think it's going to be a new game or
just like a remake
um I think this would be a I don't know
uh sympathy of Darkness or whatever that
game is is beloved
so I think they could easily make a
little bit of change doing that uh but
my thing is
I'm very big on don't bring something
back unless you're gonna do something
with it in the future agreed you know
don't
don't keep remaking stuff you know when
we saw Resident Evil
four
uh that's after we saw Resident Evil 2
remake that's after we saw Resident Evil
3 remake so I feel like there's actual
fruit behind Resident Evil 4. you know
they've actually done more than just
show one game and I'm concerned we're
seeing all these these remakes uh you
know Dead Space
Resident Evils final fantasies and I
just don't want these companies
to okay we're gonna we're gonna redo
Castlevania but they don't make nothing
new
like okay
Resident Evil is different because
they're still continuing that franchise
or Village and stuff so they get a
little bit of a pass and you know Final
Fantasy is doing pretty good too but
when it comes to dead space in this
Castlevania if this comes out and if
it's you know a remake are you going to
continue the franchise or are you just
going to make money reliving the
franchise
yeah like I I want to see a new Dead
Space game not just remakes and and I'm
okay with supporting the remakes to show
that I want a new one but if they are
they ever gonna give me the new one is
the bigger question
that's a good question um so far we
haven't seen or Resident Evil is you
know of course they have you know
they're like the Resident Evil Village
in seven but out of the remakes we
haven't seen the new one in the series
of uh like you said Dead Space uh what
some other ones
it's been quite a few yeah well you know
I'm pretty sure Saint Rose is out it's a
wrap like that ain't coming back like
um but that was a reboot though they
didn't remake that was just a reboot
yeah I I think
I mainly
that that's another question you know I
I personally feel like these companies
buy these franchises to not put money
behind them just to use their name to
make a little bit of money
and like you know
you could say that
about the
what's that
hold up they made three of them you play
as the horsemen of uh the The Four
Horsemen Darksiders Darksiders because I
felt like three didn't have a lot of
money uh funneled through it I felt like
you know Saint Row wasn't really like
they don't give them they they buy the
IPS just to sell off the name but they
don't give them the money they need to
succeed they don't give the tools they
need to succeed and I feel like these
big companies like embrace your group in
them they're ruining the industry in a
way because they're not trying to build
up that franchise they're trying to use
the name just to make money
when they try with Saints Row added to
be fair
that game had a 100 million dollar
budget so they yeah I feel you but how
much of that 100 million dollars went
towards marketing or was marketing a
different budget like did they spend 10
like 50 million and 50 million on
marketing like they don't really go into
details like that but that matters you
know if if you're spending the majority
of your
your budget on marketing what do you
realistically going to improve on and I
think that's the biggest thing and when
it comes to Castlevania
you know I think Konami is going to do a
better job than a bracer does with those
but I'm sitting here looking at this and
I'm like you know Castlevania I don't
have a huge love with it
I did like um
Castlevania it might have been called
Curse of Darkness I don't know someone
in the chat remind me it was with the
innocent devils
it was on the Xbox the original XBox and
and Playstation 2 if it was on
PlayStation two I don't know I played it
on Xbox and it was pretty much about
it was about the the Netflix characters
Hector and them so you were you were
control over Hector and you had and you
had control over innocent devils
and um you know you fought Trevor in it
it brought those characters back you
fought Dracula at the end and but see
what's funny is it's just like it was in
the Netflix show
yeah oh it was an XBox exclusive it was
just like the Netflix show
Hector was
Hector left Dracula
so you know I want to see stuff like
that you know I
I don't mind the remix I think they're
done as long as they're done well I will
accept the remakes where you lose me is
when you do nothing with the franchise
um if they want to to remake the first
Castlevania I'm pretty sure a lot of
people would be okay with that but after
you see the interest and you see the
gauge of Interest
actually build a team even if you st if
you have a team continue to work on the
remakes that's fine but actually start
building a team to move the franchise
forward because I don't want this realm
where by the time they remake all the
debt spaces and they get to a new Dead
Space
I'm 50.
because you you got this Castlevania and
then you have to go to the net I mean
you have this dead space and then you go
to the next dead space and then you go
to the next step that's six years of
development time
and no new dead space that's my biggest
issue we we want to see progression in
the franchises that we love and if
you're going to use these to sell me
dead space one I will buy it because I
love the franchise but I hope all of
this leads to us actually playing a new
game in the franchise right
I think I mean that's I think it is
clearly it depends
on if if the studios or the or the
Publishers feel that a new version of
their game will work because if if we're
buying the remix that's usually people
you know maybe in their 30s and their
40s that played the games years ago
have a desire to play them again but
what about these new gamers are are they
buying the two and see that's the big
gamble right there will the new Gamers
the new generation The Gamers were they
comment and and pick this new version
the Dead Space up where it is dead space
four you know or whatever or you know
they didn't with Saints Row
I'm I'm not saying Dead Space is going
to be what Saints Row turn out to be
but it's a gamble man it's a gamble when
you have a IP from years ago you know
but the Remake was good enough I loved
it um that I believe their space a new
Dead Space will work but even like a
game like Mass Effect Andromeda
wasn't the best game in the world but it
was the first Mass Effect game in years
and it didn't you know it didn't do that
well
um
it didn't do well but I know the game
had its issues but it didn't do well man
so
yeah I think that's where I stand the
most it's like I don't I don't mind
these games getting remade and I hope
they remake Castlevania because I feel
like
the mechanics and the gameplay that made
Castlevania work as long as it's
improved on when you remake it I think
it would do well especially coming off
the Netflix show you know we we could
easily get a popping
uh pop in Castlevania game it's just one
of those things where it's like we
actually got to see it you know it and
for the most part I think they I think
they're gonna do right by us I do I
think they're going to do right by us
it's just look
I don't want to keep going with this
Castlevania thing in this dead space
thing without seeing fruits of Labor to
okay we get the Remake I'm supporting
this ideal where does that lead this
franchise in the in the end and I think
that's that's just my biggest fear is
the fact that you know like some people
in the chat said
they don't care about the franchise they
care about the money that the remakes
could could generate and to me if you
make good debt spaces in good
castlevanias you're going to generate a
lot of excitement towards those IPS and
you're going to end up getting the money
in the long run anyway
yep I agree but that's just me though we
I don't think there's really much to to
move on I would like for them to remake
that uh Curse of Darkness uh
Castlevania really enjoyed that game I
really enjoyed it like had like RPG
mechanics I get it that's not the type
of uh gameplay mechanics that everyone's
gonna like right but I personally would
like it we're going to move on to
everyone's favorite thing to talk about
dirt what's that it is in
ft's so
first off this is definitely going to be
us talking smack about score Enix
uh because I at this point I I go out of
my way to uh you know come down on this
company that I personally feel is doing
the Xbox Community a huge disservice so
they've come out with an official an
official
shout out to two dollar Super Chat from
Sean
uh what up though
hey Sean you POS go to sleep
yeah I'm sure you could use some sleep I
could which I I'm pretty wide awake at
this point but nfts man they're coming
in a huge uh way in this in this game
I didn't really check to see what type
of game it is because I'm already
talking down on it and I just had to see
that it was an nft game
so let's let's talk about scoring in
general
it's crazy to me that they're going
above and beyond like this
and
do you think it's because of the bad
games they're making or you think
they're just generally shifting what
they do to this company
okay because to me
they're they're making okay jrpgs but
they're missing a lot too and I think
that's probably why they're trying this
nft thing and I think it's ruining their
reputation of their company in general
so to me you're just hurting yourself
trying to make more money instead of you
know just making better games
yeah I think they're bleeding bro
they're they're hurting right now but
that Avengers flopping that seemed like
that was the thing that really started
um
dislike consistency
you can tell bro you can tell like
that's a huge IP that's a huge license I
mean that's a huge license yeah Marvel
Marvel ain't cheap yeah man and not only
that game Fly but also Godzilla the
Galaxy flopped
for spoken flop listen they're bleeding
right now bro
and you know there were some other games
they published last year that didn't do
well at all like babylon's fall that
crap
they're they're struggling they're
trying to figure out some way
to make some money man because their
games just they're not doing well right
now and you know like we said for
smoking was their most recent launch
well well I guess Auto past traveler is
but you know that's the smaller game I'm
sure the budget is it
crazy like for spoken for smoking was a
100 million dollar budget man
bro they bleeding right now they're
trying to find anything
and hope it works out they don't care
about the public backlash they don't
care about none of that stuff
yeah
I think I think the biggest issue I'd be
having with this is
they be acting like the public backlash
won't hurt them
yeah it's like if that nft doesn't work
out and I don't think it's going to
because I feel like the gaming industry
is already said yo we ain't messing with
nfts like you could do what you want you
could try we're gonna boycott the hell
out of you
and I haven't really seen too many
examples of nfts succeeding in the
industry
you know you got for the most part we
might bicker around about PlayStation
versus Xbox versus Nintendo switch uh
steam deck versus switch game this game
that but I have seen the industry
privilege come back come together like
Oh you mean NFL we don't mess with nfts
like
and to me
you're going to lose so much good faith
or the little bit of your name that's
left by trying to chase a bag that
you're not even entirely sure if you can
get
hmm
once again if you want money in the
industry
scar Enix make good games
instead of blocking millions of people
that's on the Xbox platform how about
you put those games on Xbox
you know I'm sure Microsoft will give
you some a a bag for Game Pass or
something like Final Fantasy stop making
deals with PlayStation when they don't
buy your games
what happened to that same energy before
spoken
it's not like they went out there and
bought that in the masses no they didn't
because you can't hide behind that stuff
anymore
now I'm assuming the money
that score Enix got four
spoken to making it exclusive I'm sure
that helped the loss a little bit but
it's just like
I don't understand who looks at these
games and that's not all Square Enix
games are are the same they actually do
make a lot of good smaller projects like
triangle strategy octopath traveler you
know I really like these games and dial
field was okay I'm pretty sure that was
them I wouldn't give it like games of
the year best jrpg I ever played but it
was okay
um besides Final Fantasy I don't think
they're making money
yeah yeah clearly and with Final Fantasy
they put it in a box and give it to
PlayStation mm-hmm
so you know I'm not saying that you're
going to make like an absurd amount of
money off of Xbox but you're gonna make
something because there's a lot of
people that will play Final Fantasy on
the Xbox brand now when you don't put
over little games I can understand if
you're skeptical of that but Final
Fantasy is a worldwide name there is a
lot of people on the Xbox platform that
would buy that game that would play that
game on Game Pass and the fact that you
don't even try
Sony better be paying you money money
I'm I'm sure they're paying them a lot
but who knows how much it is like if you
if you look at Square in this past
history they show it off Crystal
Dynamics and Otto's Montreal Tomb Raider
IP Deus exip for 300 mil
that's not that much man
yeah Embrace a Flip Flip just the Tomb
Raider IP
to Amazon well apparently because that's
still not confirmed for 600 million so
it was like Square any seems a little
desperate man I don't think they flipped
it I think so I think they leased it
okay
that makes more sense now yeah I think
they leased the movie rights and like
making TV shows okay I wouldn't be
surprised if embrace your group still
owns that now I think
after this Activision dealt things
happens I think Microsoft needs to pick
that studio up
ask you this I'm glad you said that
because
it just seems weird to me that
screen Nicks had nothing I mean like
they had nothing for Crystal Dynamics or
all those Montreal to do
out of all of the development teams in
the world
they sent both of their those teams to
help out Microsoft
crystal diamonds Crystal Dynamics you
help out with the initiative you help
those guys out out of Montreal you help
our playground games with fable
it seems like there's something near to
me
this I mean why just go help out those
two teams maybe Microsoft asked them
they ask them for a reason you know
so I don't know man I definitely think
that's possible after this deal is over
with
do you think that when it comes to it
maybe it's just one of those
we
we can't actively go out and buy stuff
right now because of this deal
and you know maybe they're like look
like this is like one of those handshake
deals you know Phil Spencer's over there
having some kind of conversation he's
like yo come here he pulls him to into
the Next Room shuts the door locks it
when I say in the Stream can't leave you
through but you know maybe Microsoft is
interested we heard
that's so that Square Enix is selling
these Studios and you know maybe
Microsoft would be interested in buying
that when when this deal is up you know
maybe the studio that has a good
relationship with score Enix can pick
this up for pennies and we'll give you
dollars right maybe we can't do anything
right now because of this show
this conversation never happened
but
maybe we could maybe Xbox
and embrace sugar can work things out
and then embrace your group after Phil
left and brush groups like we could see
we can make a penny someone
call Square Enix
hey you know what I think you're on
something bro I think
listen excuse me I don't know how
certain things is a big business works
but I know from a on a smaller scale
if you um just say if you need something
and maybe you have the money for it but
maybe some things aren't right maybe
you're going through a divorce you don't
want your soon-to-be ex-wife to see you
spend a certain amount of money you know
I mean who knows
I've heard stories about a friend yo man
um why don't you buy this house for me
and then I'll buy from you a couple
years from now or something like that
you never know I think some of that
happened bro because it seems
I won't say obvious
but it's really making you think like
wow why are they helping on Microsoft
games
Sony didn't want them to help out
naughty dog on something EA didn't want
Crystal Dynamics to help them out on
something
you'll be solved didn't need some help
with something with with all those
Assassin Creed games they're making so
it really makes you think
hmm
so I guess we'll see soon enough I guess
if if you could have your way and
someone could pick up
they could pick up right now they pick
up Crystal Dynamics what would you have
Microsoft do with them
um
probably
um they have two teams right because one
team is working with the initiative the
other team is making Tomb Raider right
um I would love for them to stay like
like like one part of the team stay
making Tomb Raider the other part of the
team becomes the initiative
or maybe all of them become Crystal
Dynamics it doesn't matter that's a very
talented Studio there
um so I would like for those guys to
continue to work on Tomb Raider that's a
IP I would love to be under Microsoft
Hughes IP um is maybe not as big as it
used to be but it still is a big name
and though in that trilogy that Crystal
Dynamics made at like the third one
Idols Montreal made which I thought was
phenomenal also
yes I would love those teams up on the
Xbox
developing Tomb Raider Perfect Dark or
whatever else they have to do Idols
Montreal I would love for them to be up
on the Xbox because regardless of the
Galaxy I don't know if you played but
that was a phenomenal game
phenomenal game they got a lot of
potential uh they do and they can make
those type of games those huge AAA games
that we want
and and I do feel like the people I
don't always mess up their name
the people that make um Deus Ex
and I think Guardians of the Galaxy
items Raw
they're very very underrated RPG Studio
and I think they really go with the vein
that Microsoft is going on right now now
you can make an argument that Microsoft
owns too much in the RPG van and maybe
they should expand somewhere else and I
would say that's fair that's definitely
fair uh the only time I would say pick
up that studio
is if you if you get all of them for one
price and you could only get them all if
you could only get Crystal Dynamics then
you know I personally feel like
you merge Crystal Dynamics with the
initiative
they become one team I agree and like
you said one half is working on you know
Perfect Dark of one half is working on
the Tomb Raider I think
it would be cool
if
they go back because you know obviously
there's been a lot of stuff going on
perfect art and they make it a third
person
uh type of stealth mechanic game
and what would be even cool you know
I've been screaming this for a while is
you build up that universe
and then you bring Laura Croft into the
Tomb Raider uh into the perfect Dart
world
interesting because I I just think that
we don't have that MCU moments in gaming
ever where IPS work together and I think
that's the Evolution for games I really
do because right now
they have a hard time selling new IPS
correct once if you start making
universes that work with other popular
brands
yeah that continue one story
that makes sense then people will try
the game out
because they care about the actual story
that's going on
and I think that that's the next area
that's where we can go where you can
actually take a little bit of risks and
get some of these newer games out
because they're working look at the
stuff
that you see
with something like
Kingdom Hearts A lot of people don't
like Kingdom Hearts but they are able to
Advance it and give it a good run
because one of that Disney characters
and two and had Final Fantasy characters
if that worked for Kingdom Hearts to get
this Mass audience that it has why can't
it work for other stuff
and that that's that's where I would
personally want it I would want them to
you know work on that yeah if anything
just buy all the studios and merge them
with the companies that they're working
with yeah
point I mean you don't really need those
Studios you just need the talent there
yeah right
exactly that's what it's about the
talent and um Buffalo studios are
talented bro we've seen it with our own
eyes
um but I agree with you um what if like
do you remember the rumor of Calista
protocol was supposed to be in the pub G
Universe did you remember that uh no I
didn't know that you remember that yeah
and obviously don't put everything
together but do do characters that that
work similar you know the Hitman
franchise you know it it that's that's a
cool little thing man you know and you
could do a lot with the Hitman franchise
I've already suggested commanding IPS
like banjo and crash or crash and Spyro
like I feel like putting these
characters together
would sell Better Together than a wood
cell individually
because it's like how they did with the
MCU they started with Iron Man then they
added Thor Captain America I don't
remember which one then they added the
other one and then they're like you know
what
let's put Black Widow in the Iron Man
games movies let's start working in
these building blocks and now what
like what five out of the top ten of the
most sold game of movies in all time are
all MCU
and if you go further than that the top
20 probably half that list is MCU
so it's clearly it works in other forms
of media you just gotta have
a company that's willing to try it
and I think DC is gonna do it you think
so because they've already said that
their gains are going to carry over into
the movies in the and vice versa like
they're going to approach storytelling
from a game from a movie and from a
comic book since in cartoon since and no
one's ever really done something like
that
do you know the best movie tie-in game I
ever played Enter the Matrix
remember on a PS2 and original Xbox
yeah I legally remember that game the
game itself was okay but the tie-in to
The Matrix Reloaded yeah that was
perfect that was a part like there was a
part in the movie when Jada Pinkett's
character and and the other guy
they were a part in the game I should
say that wasn't in the movie
but the the game showed you what
happened
to get to the part where they showed up
in the movie you know what I'm saying
there was a part where Morpheus has
fallen off of the truck Jada Pinkett
called him with her with her car
the game showed you how they got to that
point it was amazing
but like I said the game itself was
average
but the tie-in to the movie was I think
Flawless you know what's a uh there's a
game called Lord of the Rings the third
age now it was it's not canon uh there's
some things in the story that doesn't
really make sense narrative wise to the
Lord of the Rings movies but what they
do and what they do a good job is like
they take the they take the universe of
Lord of the Rings and they add to it to
a way that makes sense but if you watch
the movies that's not how it went down
like in the original when Gandalf fell
off the because it's a turn-based RPG so
when Gandalf like took the the demon and
they fell down the giant you know
endless black hole it seemed like it's I
don't know how he goes from falling to
on top of a mountain fighting him as
gandal off the white we won't go there
but so you look at something like that
in in third age you end up they end up
fighting
uh with Gandalf fighting the Demon
before he he fell so I think stuff like
that is pretty cool we got a 10
subscribe from gamer by choice I heard
from very unreliable sources that Xbox
is working with embracer on something
but if it happens quesanti may be right
and brysher was holding Studios possibly
again moon size grain of salt
I think there's a good chance that
something like that's going down now if
it goes down that's a different question
because when you got Amazon barking up
because it might have been okay we're
gonna do this and we're going to
you know hold on to it to Microsoft
gets everything done maybe that was the
original plan but plans change now der
I'm asking you
from a if you're sitting there in your
company like uh you know embracer group
and Amazon hits you up and offers you
all this money
just to use the movie rights
maybe you start seeing the value before
you can give it to Microsoft or sell it
to Microsoft
um yeah unless they had uh
a verbal agreement
um
but I don't know if that's legal like I
feel like the only way this works I hold
up in court yeah yeah I feel like the
only way this works is
if they if they if they actually stand
by their word like I I'm very confident
that at any time
if embrace your group realizes uh you
know that those IPS are more valuable to
them what they were good I mean it might
do something just as simple as like
we'll sell you the game license or you
know if we sell you the license you have
to you have to have a contract saying
that you'll you'll sell us the movie
license kind of like um what Spider-Man
did I don't know if that's exactly how
it works but to me the only way that
works is that they get everything and I
do feel like you're getting to the point
where embrace your group might see more
value on holding on to it maybe it'll
just double the price who's gonna sell
it to you for 500 million
now now that no for 300 million now we
want 500 million I I don't know how
that's gonna work maybe if all the
studios are what that Microsoft would
pay that kind of money
I don't know
uh I'm finding it hard to believe that
that gets up in the billions I don't
know if Microsoft would do that
maybe they would just let that those
Studios go
yeah I don't think those studios are
worth billions
yeah no the thing is is the Tomb Raider
franchise is definitely worth something
yeah but
are you going to be able to negotiate a
a fair price that both parties accept
and I don't know because you have Amazon
just think about that Amazon either
bought the Tomb Raider license or
license out TV shows that are movies
it's hard to believe what they what they
did that for it's hard to believe how
how much money they put into that they
they could have literally paid off that
deal just by licensing out the Tomb
Raider deal to Amazon
and when you see that money
you're like wow you know maybe
maybe I can actually do this
yeah
I guess I guess we'll find out soon
enough I guess maybe next year later
this year
yeah so I mean we're gonna move on to
the Xbox stuff man we got pretty light
show this week you know I guess we'll
talk about the uh the
Microsoft thing here in a second because
I know some of you like to talk about
that um the ab day kill ABK kill uh deal
I'm just done with it man but we'll talk
about Xbox in 2023. you know I
personally feel like they're gonna have
a good year
you know even if hellblade doesn't come
out this year
that's a solid year they've had now
obviously the game's got to come out and
deliver you know we're not saying that
they're going to get automatic good
scores from the start uh but I think we
can all agree on paper right now
Microsoft has good odds of having a good
year would you not agree Dart
absolutely I agree
um I think they have a chance to have
at least uh a solid chance to have Elise
one to two games nominated for Game of
the Year first party you know
if hellblade comes out
it's definitely two you know but I
believe
um if you just look at the lineup
it's a good year
yeah and then you know the good thing
about stuff what's going on too is
Game Pass you know we're seeing them
really focus on Game Pass we're seeing a
lot of stuff in general with Game Pass
and I think that that with their actual
titles you're seeing a huge influx of
games that you could play it at any time
that's what people need to realize look
I don't think I've never seen anyone
just straight up give Microsoft excuses
for not having games
but I've said this a couple times
they are very good at showing us yo we
might not have a game for you this month
but we got two semi-popular games that
you could play right on Game Pass and so
you know when you got like games like
Persona dropping
you know I think people forget that we
just want to play games it doesn't
matter first party it doesn't matter
third party doesn't matter second party
I think people forget that so when you
have stuff like that happening
and you have these games happening on
Game Pass
all you're really doing is distracting
and that's all you have to really do now
obviously those games got to come out
eventually they got to no one's ever
going to say they don't but it helps to
keep the heat off of Microsoft when
they're like
yo star if it ain't gonna be here this
month
but we got these three games for you to
play
and when it's it's like and we look most
of the main shiny new toys but to us
they are then when you give the the
entry is just a subscription a game pass
you could jump in here and play these
games all month and you by the end of
the month you're like oh yeah where's
star filled man where's this game at and
then guess why then guess what's gonna
happen dirt oh we don't have star for
you this month either but we got these
three games now oh okay I'll see you
next month I'll start complaining again
next month like
it doesn't accept or excuse for the lack
of games but I will say
it's hard to complain about something
when you have something to do
yeah like um
what sea of stars because there's a game
called sea of stars that's hidden game
pass I don't know if you saw it
what the jrpg see you first I know I
didn't see it
yeah
um
listen Adam you've been around long
enough you know most of this this
conversation this console war talk
um yeah definitely yeah because even
even I criticize the Xbox one generation
but at this at the same time I love my
Xbox one especially when I got the Xbox
One X I never had a game that I wasn't I
mean I never had a time where I wasn't
playing games
the exclusive talk it's it's only
console war banter
um like last year Xbox had no first
party
they were making fun of us this year all
they have is Spider-Man guess what we're
gonna do
we're gonna make fun of you guys so even
last year there was something
third-party exclusives huh it's a give
and take yeah exactly yeah you could
give it you you can go in there and and
you could tag me on on Twitter stuff
but don't get it twisted
I'm gonna take those Jabs when I can
yeah
um see but this thing I remember last
year hearing people saying you know
because Xbox has some third-party games
um that was going into Game Pass and
exclusive like high on life and those
games don't count me third party okay
so guess who it's it's our turn to make
fun this year so it's all about console
war banter we always have some games to
play
you know you look at the PS2 generation
the PS1 generation the exclusives were
third party mostly you know I mean of
course there was a few exclusives uh
like first party exclusive but most of
the big games on PS1 was third party
Metal Gear Solid you know Final Fantasy
VII you know stuff like that so it was
all about console war talk
yeah I I at this point man
I just I just I want to Starfield
because I enjoy it but let's go over
these you know the games that we see now
obviously these can get delayed uh you
know I hate to say that but you know
that that's it is what it is so you guys
see it thieves apparently season nine uh
nines is coming out here soon or it's
already out
you got Forza Horizon 5 uh rally
Adventure you got Minecraft Legends
redfall uh Elder Scrolls Online uh
necron
you got star filled and you got Forza
um I don't know what happened to dirt
dirt's gone
what happened to dirt
hold up guys
dirt left
he got tired of us man
well he
is dirt talking
is is dirt still talking guys
oh my God you guys are ridiculous
he closed his eyes shut up
uh you guys making me think he's there
and it's just my screen and you playing
some jokes some inside joke you and dirt
huh
yeah it looks like he gone uh you know
could have lost power
is a bunch of different things
yeah I'm alone with you guys I I I'm
nervous man I'm looking around looking
for my exits you know imagine
having 234 people around you
you know that that that's that's a
that's a little army you know
I I could take over I I you know there's
places I couldn't take over 234 people
but there's a lot of places you can
the void with the people
I'd be I'd be scared I'd be scared
well I sent the invite back to him we
only got one little topic left
so I don't think it's gonna matter too
much you know just sit here and talk
I don't see dirt but he's not talking
you could see Dart buddies let's see now
I don't believe any of you
let you in
it's not saying that you have a a guest
that's appeared let me just generate a
new link
Dart
hey just join this new link
sometimes they'd be messing up
let him cook dirt is like a canoeing
he's using a camouflage you guys are you
guys are so
extra man you guys are so extra
you guys are ridiculous he's bleeding
into the background he's a chameleon
this is dirt at full power
just tell me when you click on it so I
can uh
no one to make sure to to bring you in
because normally it tells me at the
bottom when someone's joined
is not telling me
had a complete utter failure today
you clicked on it
actually
dirt just get on Discord
we don't got time for all this dirt just
get on Discord
do we have each other on Discord dirt
send me a message on Discord dirt
send me one
my Discord is just crazy
it's just insane
it's everywhere
I'm looking for for dirt now
I feel like you sent me a message on
Discord before
but I don't
see it
you guys are getting way
way too amused off of this
I I will blame the series s thank you
just tell me whatever you send that
message dirt
get dirt back in here
I guess we could talk about the
PlayStation 5 Pro
yeah just jump in um
go ahead and jump in cog's nation
yeah that'll work jump in that
it's in the iron Lords Discord it's
called cog's Nation
just jump in that and turn your camera
on
yeah we're going to talk about that real
quick actually let me
let me make
PS5 Pro
let me do that while he's coming in here
there we go
because I actually made a video on that
you know definitely go check that out on
the
on the the game he had a YouTube channel
because I got a lot to say about this
PlayStation 5 Pro
yo and I don't think it's a good thing
at all
whatsoever
dirt you could just send me a message if
you want you know you don't if you're
not in the iron Lord server just send me
a message
yeah we're gonna talk about that you
know even if Dart is having some
technical issues and I have to talk
about it by myself we're going to talk
about that because I don't like it I
don't like it at all there's there's
specific reasons I don't like it either
I just don't like it
where are you Dart
I apologize guys I don't
I don't know what's going on with uh
ah stop it with that am I happy with
anything
you guys be acting like I can't
criticize something without hating it me
criticizing that's all I know how to do
is criticize something it don't mean I
hate it it just means I have ways that I
felt like they could have improved it I
got things I don't like just just send
me a message uh
we'll get you in that here in a second
just send me a message
here's the username dirt
I think you texted me once I don't think
you sent it
uh no how
this program works it's on stream Labs
is I send them a link and they join like
any other thing like streamlabs uh
stream yards or anything it just seems
like it's buggy
or gimmicky I should go back to zoom you
know I might end up going back to zoom
next week I don't know
I felt like this was less taxing on my
computer
but we'll see how it goes
this is the first time it's ever kicked
anyone out like upright though usually
There's issues like I can't hear at the
beginning but they've never just
straight up kicked someone out
and so you know I might give it one more
attempt and if there's ever an issue
again
we back on Zoom man we back on Zoom
until I know
they have fixed the issue
let me double check and make sure
there's no patreon questions I don't
think there was but I didn't check
because I
I looked last night and I didn't see any
so
no there is a
do you need me to put it back in the
chat
dirt
uh I hope it's nothing that serious
people just trying to get rid of dirt
from speaking
oh
man I'm
I woke up like 15 minutes before five by
the way guys
I don't know what's going on
I apologize guys you know we might have
to just uh just call it a day you know
I talk about
finish what's going on
and then you know we'll call it a day oh
hold up hold up
there's dirt
hello
I think I gotta switch my headset
settings
yeah can you hear me
yeah I can't hear you hold on can you
hear me yes I can hear you dirt is back
and my camera has messed up I don't know
what that's about
ah I don't know what's going on bro that
was crazy like it has kicked me out
then I was clicking on the links but it
wouldn't I don't know what the hell's
going on bro
yeah
I don't know if it was like
a browser thing
or if it was like a
a
[Music]
um
just an issue in general
all right hold up let me resize the
cameras
yeah I don't know if my camera work
because every time I'm on Discord I try
to use my camera it never works right I
don't know why if it doesn't work it
doesn't work
I see all these jokes y'all y'all pos's
yeah they they were they was uh I
thought I thought it was messed up you
know I thought that you were there
because the way they were describing it
you're still there I just couldn't hear
they're trying to say the dark the dark
picture was me these pos's I never
forget I saw them in the chest State
dirt just smile we could see I was like
oh my God yeah man ain't me man
yeah so all right let's we'll just keep
it this way guys you know apologize for
the inconvenience I could probably go to
zoom but I at this point we closed into
the show I don't want to jump through a
bunch of Hoops with dirt we'll just
finish it like this dirt let's let's
I didn't
how
what's what I'm looking for
there's a lot of stuff going on right
now
and one of the biggest things that I
forgot to put in the the titles and
maybe it's because I was already going
to talk about it on my personal channel
so I forgot to put it on here is the
PlayStation 5 Pro
uh you know
let's talk about that man what's your
overall perspective on cross on you know
uh gen upgrades do you like that or like
how did you feel the Xbox One and PS4
generation when they did it last year I
I'm sorry last generation it made sense
especially on the Xbox side because I
got Tyler here in the 720p
900p it made sense
um
now I understand a slim edition of a
console I totally get that but this
doesn't make sense this generation is
it's two years into the generation a
little over two years
I haven't seen any game that's truly
utilizing the power of these consoles
hell
we heard the rumor about no um Last of
Us factions is going to be on PS4
also so what the hell we need a major
refresh for
it just makes no sense to me on both
sides it doesn't make any sense to me we
haven't even seen the power of these
consoles yet man so
no I'm not feeling it I'm not feeling it
at all like I said last generation it
made more sense this time it doesn't
I agree
um let me turn that back on and off I
actually feel like
we gave them too much power
because I I don't believe just
PlayStations doing this most likely this
is being done Xbox is doing the two
and I feel like we may have
we may have been too willing
to buy the Xbox One X and the PS4 Pro
because now this is why we always say
don't give in to anything because
they'll use those numbers to justify
doing it again
and now because people went out they
bought the PlayStation 5 PlayStation 4
Pro and the Xbox One X why wouldn't
these companies feel like they can get
away with it yeah and it's sad because
it's like you said I felt like Xbox One
made sense
and um
the PlayStation 4 made sense but at the
same time
I don't know if it makes sense now
nope
I feel like the pandemic kind of slowed
the generation down a little bit oh
absolutely and there's no way you could
sit here and realistically tell me
that they've used these consoles to that
degree because I I I would disagree
facts
I agree with you man and I'm worried
okay it would be different if we had
Xbox One exclusives
if we had PS Xbox One X exclusives and
we had PS5 Pro exclusives
I would agree with you a little bit in
that matter because I'm like okay
at least we're gonna see Bears of fruit
with this upgrade
but as we saw last generation with mid
gen upgrades
there's nothing different you the games
will just play stuff a little bit better
that's all you know uh five final
scripture from macau28 PR I hope I
spelled your name right but pronounce it
right Phil said they never lose the
power narrative to Sony again let them
make a pro
see I don't like that though because
then Place Xbox
if PlayStation is making a pro Xbox has
no choice but to respond
yeah they have no choice yep and we're
getting really really dicey areas now
because at that point you'll end up
starting to see a cell phone model show
up and I don't know about you guys I
don't want that kind of cell phone model
nope I'm I'm cool
with game with Generations lasting like
anywhere from seven to eight years I'm
cool with that me too
and if we give them the ability to have
these mid-gen refreshes
you're gonna have to buy consoles every
two three years
and that's crazy man
we are not ready for that
we you know it I I guess it would be
better the reason the cell phone market
works the way it does is because there's
a lot of ways that you can get into the
cell phone market without paying a lot
of money
you know Sprint all these places they
have you know these programs to where if
you trade your phone in you can upgrade
to the next model if you want
but
the gaming industry don't really have
this type of this type of uh you know
programs
right you know I guess you could turn
the the all-access program that
Microsoft does you can turn that into it
but I don't think that's gonna work the
way people think
no yeah I agree with you
um it's just man yeah I agree with you
man like
I'm the type I just want the games
um a year generation that's fine
um because towards the end of that
generation we're going to see the best
of these consoles
and I bro we haven't even scratched the
surface of these consoles yet
all right not at all it's like and plus
I think I'm scared of dirt is you're
gonna get a lot of games they're just
buggy
because when you keep adding more skus
for these developers to work on
now a lot of the higher up people
they're going to be able to do it
because they got the money the resources
but when you go to these like double A
Indie type of Studios they don't got the
money for that stuff they don't got the
Manpower guess what you'll see you'll
see more and more games skipping the
Lesser lead platforms because it doesn't
like look at it indie game very popular
indie game
um I'm not going to really go into
specifics on a certain indie game but if
you look be the developer for that one
talking to Publishers a publisher
talking to people finding out exactly
what's the best way to sell this game
they don't have the money to Port this
game five times they have the money to
Port at once
who they gonna go to Dirk
they're gonna go to the market leader
bro yeah and that's why it's just like
this is a bad model and for all types of
scenarios
um look what happened with the Xbox One
X and the PS4 Pro there was multiple
games that were damn near unplayable on
the Xbox One and PS4 that works semi on
the Xbox One X and PS4 Pro did it not
um and to me
that's giving developers a okay
we're we're still we're essentially
going to develop on the Xbox One X and
just make sure it runs on the Xbox One
so they're they're pretty much forcing
you to upgrade
but not forcing you to upgrade
and I don't think people want that
because once you start going that
direction
then the research and development goes
straight down the drain why research
this console for years at a time find
that works best find out what we can do
the most when we could just upgrade the
GPU next year and give us a little bit
more memory
and pop that sucker out call it that you
know what's up the PlayStation 5 pro pro
you know what's so crazy though
they're still games that's releasing on
PS4 and Xbox we saw how Hogwarts just
got another delay we see like game like
uh all the sports games still released
on last generation consoles WWE 2K 23
just came out it's released it released
on the PS4 and and also the Xbox One hey
now it's like okay come on now I get
slim models yes I I love the slim models
they're cool that's when the casuals
usually really start to buy the consoles
when when there's a slim model available
but I just no man see I don't consider
the slim models like a next skew I
consider it a skew that's been great
imagined just the better yeah just
reimagining just a better version of
that console and that's fine
but like with the Xbox One and the PS4
people were saying they were
underpowered from the beginning at
launch people send them Jaguar cars are
trash it's underpowered blah blah blah
so yeah the mid-gen refreshes made sense
nobody's really saying I mean what was
well like some haters on the Xbox series
s but
these consoles aren't you know weak
actually people are we're hearing
developers that's gonna be more work for
them if they have to develop for the
some some games for the Xbox One PS4 PS5
um the PS5 Pro Xbox series X Xbox series
s for Xbox series Pro like that bro
that's going to be more consoles they
have to in the PlayStation
right the PlayStation 5 Pro pool VR2 Pro
it's like come on man stop it this is
too much and plus I do think dirt that
making these
these console manufacturers
stand on their Square
okay you only released in this once so
you better make sure that you really sit
down and you think and you innovate and
you make sure that the PS5 was the best
it could be the Xbox series s and X were
the best it can be because you only
release them once
and then by the time you release new
consoles it's the Next Generation I feel
like when you start giving them the
options to release that out
you're gonna get
oh we wanted to do this but we had we
can't wait and I feel like there's an
issue in that and I I don't know man I I
personally feel like it's a
it is a bad thing to do that's just me
we got a five dollar super shot for the
angry therapist MD I don't think they
even began to scratch the surface of
this uh consoles facts bro we're just
we're just now getting games that's only
on these gen consoles yeah
and so I added so they're saying the PS5
Pro can probably be next year pro pro
the only way I would be okay with them
making a refresh is if it came
out in 2026 and it added like four more
years to the generation like the
generation lasted 10 years that's only
where I would be okay with it that'll be
six years into the Generation Now
obviously most Generations don't even
last you know will last six years uh
last generation lasted seven years the
360 generation lasted eight years but
this is like nah man that's that's no no
way not yet
it's it's a mistake man and you know
and the sad part is I could sit here and
tell you guys not to support it
but if they buy you got to because if
you want to play games I have a feeling
that games are going to run dramatically
better on the PlayStation 5 Pro than
they do on the PlayStation 5.
and it's sad because it's like
you're not defining anything you're just
putting a Band-Aid on it
exactly man and you know I think this
works out better for for PlayStation as
Xbox because at least PlayStation
doesn't really stay in date with PC
because now you have given because
PlayStation is doing this
you give an Xbox like this huge
disadvantage because at least
PlayStation could just focus on the
PlayStation 5 and PlayStation 5 Pro Xbox
got to focus on the Xbox series s the
Xbox series X the Xbox series X version
2 the Xbox series s version 2 and PC
developing games
yeah that's that's a lot of stuff man
now
how would you feel about them just
releasing a stronger Xbox series s
that would that wouldn't I feel like
that's still a very yeah
what about the millions of people that
already have the s
they're like damn I just bought this now
the new or stronger version
I just should have bought the X
let's see you know so no I can't see
that either bro
it's it's a weird conversation man and
you know
what do you think the odds of this is
like on a one uh on like a one to 100
scale
right now I'm going to say 50 because
I don't believe it will but I wouldn't
be surprised
I'm gonna say 70 30.
really I I do think there's a very high
chance that this could happen
yeah because the Xbox One X and the
PlayStation 4 Pro was so successful
uh you know they obviously they gonna
squeeze every drop
of lemon from this suckers they can
and if they can release these consoles
they generally want to make money off of
software that's where they make the
majority of their money off of from
selling third-party stuff like Call of
Duty to selling their first party stuff
you know the only difference is they
make more money
you know
if Microsoft buys Call of Duty instead
of making only 30 percent when they sell
Call of Duty they're gonna make a
hundred percent
so it actually makes more sense for the
for a console manufacturer to own Call
of Duty because they're bringing in more
of the pie at that point because they're
not sharing with anyone that's I think
that's one of the reasons that Sony
doesn't want that going through is
because
people don't realize the amount of power
that Call of Duty has they just don't
and you know
well what is it it's it's 6 18. okay
this is the deal guys
I'm not talking about this ABK deal all
day I'm just not it's not happening
I will give you guys till 6 30 and we
will talk about it but after that is a
wrap we done like because because I just
I it's just not appealing to me man so
okay well let me do the timestamp police
we're talking about ABK from one hour
we'll say 19 minutes
and that's the ABK okay dirt
tell me what's going on with the ABK
deal
well adding my man
Xbox is uh signing a lot of deals
10-year deals with
Cloud stream Services uh it just seems
like to me Xbox is daring these
Regulators to block this deal because
they're addressing all of their concerns
in my opinion some of the concerns were
um
there will be less people that will play
Call of Duty they're like no there's
gonna be more people Xbox keep on saying
there's going to be more people more
people and they're signing these deals
with everybody they signing with
Nintendo Nvidia these other two
companies I can't even I don't even know
their damn names without looking at it
and so it just goes to show you that
Xbox is serious about this deal
um I saw something earlier was talking
about how much of these uh mobile
companies made last year
it's absolutely ridiculous and it goes
to show you the Xbox it's not just about
Call of Duty they're like listen y'all
can keep Call of Duty on your damn
consoles or cloud or whatever they don't
care
is more than Call of Duty for Microsoft
they want that mobile
mobile mate where's that I I retweeted
mobile um
the top three mobile
games well not games but companies 10
cent with 32 billion now this is in 2022
billion with a B with a B apple with
14.8 billion Google with 12.4 billion
Xbox wants to be in there Microsoft
wants to be in there so it's about more
than Call of Duty
we know who's crying about Call of Duty
looking man y'all don't want to sign the
deal but we're going to show these
Regulators that we mean business we're
signing 10-year deals with companies
I've never heard of the company they
signed with today they announced that
they signed with today they would
accomplished that's supporting some
things to the Nintendo switch through
the uh like Cloud uh streaming you know
things like that so
it's crazy man how
this deal man like added this year
this deal has exposed so much stuff
about business behind it scenes words
too I think so bro
when these contracts are leaked
it's about to be damned it's gonna be
wild bro
it's gonna be wild
um
so it's just it's just like wow man I
just like I say all the time I
I've lost a lot of respect for
you know PlayStation
um some of the things they're
complaining about I understand from a
business Point not wanting Xbox to you
know on Call of Duty but at the same
time they're saying they're going to
take it away but Xbox will say no let's
sign the damn contract we're not going
to take it away and it just keeps on
being this I know I don't know man it's
on keeping on man keep on keeping on
and the crazy thing is you know first
off we got 230 people in the chat hit
that like button if you guys don't mind
let's get that above 150 you know I I
that's what I would prefer
[Music]
I just
I guess with this I'm just so tired of
talking about it because it just feels
like
it's the same conversations
um Sony shouldn't own a Sony Microsoft
should own Call of Duty because they
can't they can't be trusted Sony
shouldn't do this because they can't be
trusted Sony's weak and they can't
compete because of this Microsoft can do
this because of that it's just like
we wanted
messy Microsoft and Sony but I want it
like this it was like
and I guess I've just gotten to the
point where it's like
okay at this point
I'm not gonna lie I would and I know
it's never gonna happen I would low-key
prefer
place the Xbox just dropped the case
like we ain't buying Activision
uh I know that's not gonna happen
there's too much money on the line but
me as a content creator talking about
Xbox
amodir like I I I'm just I'm
I'm mentally drained from talking I
understand that I understand that I said
I understand you uh because sometimes I
am also
but it's still a very popular topic bro
it is this is not possible yeah I got
you but it's still like a very popular
topic
um
yeah it's kind of the same thing same
thing here same thing there but
we get things like Lulu out there
talking trash man she's calling out very
spicy she's very spicy
I love it bro and what's funny is we
always say we want these Executives to
be real to stop corporate speaking to
stop PR speaking and then you got
someone like Lulu that just says what's
on her mind
and she's not being professional make up
your mind
added like you know how it goes they say
what they they say stuff and then when
it happens they don't mean it for the
longest they say they want Xbox to
compete they want Xbox to act like a
trillion dollar company they those guys
set that for the longest now the Xbox is
doing that what are they doing they've
been saying for years they want Xbox to
act like a real company yep but they
want Xbox to act like a real company
without affecting Sony exactly you know
they people like oh you know spend money
in the Microsoft spread money no go put
the world away
you don't have to keep doing this like I
like to play Call of Duty on the
PlayStation 5. exactly bro we'll let you
know we'll let you still play Call of
Duty on the PlayStation 5 but what
happens if they change their mind in 10
years
right in 10 years oh man I'm telling you
it's crazy Xbox One be around 10 years
right I'm saying man Xbox has no games
Xbox has a monopoly that makes
absolutely no sense
I feel like people are getting more and
more extra with the way they go about
talking about this
because if you remember at the beginning
there's a lot of like PlayStation
Centric individuals in the community
they'll say oh this is never going to
get uh you know this is going to go
through there's no reason this shouldn't
go through it's not a monopoly but now
since there is a a chance that this can
get blocked now they're completely
talking different well you know it's
about consolidation you know I just I
don't like consolidation and I feel like
this is you know this particular
incident isn't an issue it's what can
happen afterwards and then I I hit them
up I'm like well explain to me first off
shout out to five dollars project from a
adidas20 zero
I definitely put you today we're gonna
move right past that though what's up
what up bro how you doing man
yeah so my thing with this is like you
look at something like this
and I always ask them I said explain the
difference between me to me
of Sony
locking down the majority of Square Enix
games
and all those games for the most part on
coming on an Xbox platform sure they
might go on a switch platform but guess
what else um Ori went on the switch
platform banjo is constantly being used
on the search platform I to me
they they both of them don't consider
switch is like a huge competitor even
though switch is beating them both
uh so when you look at something like
that and you really break down the Nitty
Gritty stuff what's the difference
you know maybe time can restraint I I
could see people argument there but to
me it's not even time restraint because
some of these companies are
never putting their their games on the
Xbox platform uh for instance Final
Fantasy VII remake that's not on the
platform rebirth isn't coming on the
platform and most likely that's going to
go around the same you know Lane that
Final Fantasy 7 remake did so for
smoking never came on the platform Final
Fantasy 16 isn't on the platform I
remember
Phil was talking about making sure Final
Fantasy 14 was on Xbox and then out of
nowhere that just went out that never
got brought back up
um they refused to comment on it uh to
me
in both scenarios
only one company is getting attacked and
the other company is doing a similar
thing but he's just buying the studio to
me it should be the other way around you
should attack Sony for not investing
into an ecosystem they keep using as a
bag of exclusives for timed exclusives
unless on the company that's buying and
actually investing into the company that
they're actually working with
but for some reason that is only issued
at Xbox when PlayStation has went above
and beyond to make sure that Xbox
customers don't get the majority of
score Enix games
yeah
that's crazy right that's crazy bro
um
yeah
it is man um
Xbox is not only
Investing For for their first party and
their service Xbox game pass but they're
also helping out the developers man um I
don't know if you saw the
the double fine documentary is it was
long but I watched it and there was a
part no I think it was episode 24 25
where
there were some episodes where double
fine they needed money
they needed money to finish this game
cyclonize two and they you know like Tim
Schaefer had to borrow half a million
dollar or a quarter of a million dollars
from a friend
and they were looking for money they
went to Microsoft
hey you know what I think are we um want
to buy you guys
and so oh okay
but let's look how much do I get like
yeah so they're like someone a half a
million dollars how much do I get
so Tim Schaefer also said how it feels
great to know that they don't have to
shop their game around to Publishers
um they know that they have the money to
get to do what they need to do and they
just focus on the game part they don't
have to focus on the finance part and
not just them Ninja Theory was in a bad
place before Xbox acquired them so
they're they're they have saved teams
that that's making games for us
like why wouldn't you want that
naughty people mad about that is the
PlayStation Fanboys why wouldn't you
want that I want Square Enix to go to
Sony they ain't doing nothing else
I think
I think the biggest issue
oh sorry about that I think the biggest
issue is people don't want to admit what
people's true motives are you know when
it comes to the the APK thing
I think that
that deal Works multiple ways for
PlayStation and Xbox and this isn't
about whether or not PlayStation compete
this isn't about IPS this is about
strictly monetary value PlayStation
knows that that's a law of bargaining
chips to give to anyone
and if right now sure it's not going to
issue 10 years from now
that's an issue
for PlayStation because they know that
Microsoft can go up to them and they
could say yo
we're going to put Call of Duty we're
going to keep this deal
blue on 50 50 now
now when you not when someone buys Call
of Duty on your platform I want that
extra 20 percent
what's Sony gonna do
there's no bargaining they don't own it
it's the only thing go to they're gonna
say yes we'll give you the 50 50. that's
fine biker theft can we sign another
10-year deal and then let's say Call of
Duty is that like even I know sound
crazy but 10 years from that let's say
it's like at the height of its power
um
then what they go back to the the
talking points and now
Xbox is like well it's been years since
we bought Activision
you know we still want 50 50 but we're
gonna have time to exclusive on our
end
and what were they gonna do nothing and
I think
I think they want to stop that
I think that's
they want to make sure that that is not
a Direction they can go
and I don't blame Sony for doing it I
get mad at them because they act like
they're the victim and they're doing the
same thing on a smaller scale that's the
only thing I have an issue with it yep I
agree
absolutely there you act like a victim
and like you say they're doing the same
thing they've done the same thing for
years
for years so that's the thing that
pisses me off I'm not
upset necessarily um that Sony you know
they're trying to protect their business
because that's what businesses do
but I am upset that they're acting like
the victim they're mad because Xbox has
become more aggressive and like you said
doing some of the things that
PlayStation has done in the past to hurt
Xbox
they've they have intentionally done
things to hurt Xbox but guess what
that's part of business I get it
okay so Xbox is finally using their
resources
using um you know they fully uh well
they they have Microsoft fully behind
them and people are losing their mind
over that bro yeah and you know we got
two I'll switch out from uh flame he
says to be honest place they can keep
for spoken you know what Joe if I had
access to the IOP which I do I just have
to switch scenes on you doing that
um I would put uh you on to something
because uh I don't want for spoken
either if that's the funny thing
PlayStation probably funded a lot of for
spoken I just dirt why how do these
companies play these games and think
it's going to sell well there's no way
they thought that first spoken was going
to be that hate that all game oh man I
don't know
I don't know man I feel like some of
these people might be out of touch
before actually he's doing good and
what's not doing good right now
and then we got to realize they started
developing on this three years ago three
to four I don't know exactly the time
frame I'd assume three to four so in
three or four years that that could be
ex like vastly different in terms of
scale and stuff and I think that's the
biggest issue that people don't realize
when it comes to development these
developers aren't making a game a year
ago they're making games off of
Standards three years ago three to four
years ago so by the time the game
actually comes out maybe it's shifted
away from it now a lot of studios are
able to successfully navigate around
these really Rough Waters these murky
Waters but it's not an easy thing to
navigate and I think that
there's a lot of cringe I think a lot of
the cringe stuff that you see come from
games like you know especially Japanese
games is because the translation from
sub to dub
that dialogue is acceptable in Japan and
you know a lot of parts in the East but
we have different social expectations
when it comes to stuff we have different
slang what doesn't sound cringy to them
sounds cringy to us and then you got to
think about just the translations in
general when people translate one gay
language to another game language
it doesn't come out the best because
I've seen I remember I saw a tick tock
talking about translation stuff they're
usually how that sometimes they have
like Eastern people that doesn't live in
the western Society translate from
Japanese to English like for dubbed and
to me I think that's part of the issue
because they don't know the slang we use
here they don't know how we talk here
you know we might be different in terms
of where we live from the west coast to
the north of to the central coast to the
east coast but we might say this stuff
differently in Boston from New York but
as a society we have a certain way of
talking about certain things and to me
you need someone in the states to
actually dub those types of games
yeah see that see the thing is but they
should um
if you want to talk about forespoken
specifically
they maybe should have did a little bit
more research with that game because
they did use African-American woman yeah
butcher the New York accent too like
Yeah man they use the trick from the
hood so sometimes you have to
you know have a little bit of
authenticity there or more authentic I
should say
you know so yeah I understand what
you're saying but some with certainly I
wonder situations they should deal with
better research bro I wonder if that
game was supposed to be a different game
and they change it Midway through
because of all like the Civil Rights
stuff that was going on over here
they felt like casting a black female
character
because to me
that character was so out of pocket how
she speaks and stuff that you know
because I've been to New York uh once
and I I'm I do podcasts with people from
New York
she don't talk like any of them so to me
she said it kind of felt like she was
shoehorned in there a little bit uh
but you know uh level one gaming he says
I'm tired of black people from the hood
stereotypes in our characters so you got
people like uh you know him that is on
the adjacent that's like you know uh
people of color speak different ways too
I think it's a murky area and I don't
think necessarily that's a black and uh
you know any kind of racial thing
because I feel like that's mainly to
where they are like uh black people
speak differently in New York uh white
people speak differently in New York but
a lot of them have that same accent does
that make sense and I think that was
what was primarily missing from this
individual was that accent some of the
slangs that New York uses I think that
was the the biggest issue like like I'm
dead ass D I'm dead assy
you know me I'm dead ass it's just
something it's murky Waters and I feel
like it's it's very hard to navigate uh
because that's also what happens when
you know people don't take character
development seriously so for instance
Square Enix probably should have reached
out to like a western Studio or a
western uh company to like really go
over that's why you see especially when
it comes to people butchering
uh stuff like you know uh people of
color hairstyles you know when you have
people that are literally not around the
people because I I there's black people
in Japan but I would assume the the
percentage is small compared to anything
else uh definitely because I I have been
told people because uh my friend Jansen
he he was stationed there he said you
don't even see a lot of white people
there like for the most part it's it's
entirely Asian demographic yeah it's
just but it's one of those things where
like the companies need to take that
seriously like they need to like reach
out to Studios that started well you
know
or you know bring over someone to call
consultate you know braid hairstyles for
from the states over you know go over
some of the things pay that person good
money to go over them like that ain't it
that's what you know these are the 10
most popular hairstyles in America right
now
and we need those on the gate and then
go over them and I feel like you'll see
a a change in how things are going but
at the end of the day I I honestly think
that a lot of these companies don't care
they they
they just do whatever the bare minimum
they can to get the game out the door
a uh
let me say this right quick before you
get the super chat I always say I don't
know why the black characters in The
Games always got to sound like you know
the deaf Loop guy or or you know guy
from Final Fantasy VII like come on man
not all black people sound like hey
sucker you know
Who Am you come here boy hey how you
doing yeah come over here what's funny
is it's like I said they
there's a difference between
representation
and actually representation like just
putting black people in your game or you
know Latin uh Latino people like that's
not good enough you have to actually get
the culture that they
respectively belong to
and I think most people respect GTA
yeah because GTA don't care man they
they they they they you know what GTA do
GTA not Eve only represents people from
different uh cultures but they get the
sub grouping of those cultures you know
what I'm saying like they get like like
the like the the small minority people
that act different in everyone and
they're everywhere in GTA and that's why
I honestly do think that when it comes
to stuff like this it got it it's got to
feel natural because if there's anything
that people can sense in quickness it's
forced stuff and anything when you feel
like you're forcing anything for a
narrative
and it's just it's it's frustrating man
because the gaming industry I love the
industry I feel like there's a lot of
issues in the industry and right now
it's gotten to the point where people
rather shoehorn stuff
instead of making interesting games
revolved around character
and it's sad and then you know
we got to get to the point where you
know we can we can look inside of
ourselves
before we could have conversations with
other people too
yep
what's the point the series X tools of
man look at it look at you guys they
going crazy in this chat today Xbox
isn't based in Japan we're not talking
about that we're talking about
Japanese developers making games based
on people that aren't in Japan
yeah are you see the Super Chat oh yeah
we got a two dollar strip chat from
Grumble grumble uh where are you from
attic I'm from Tucson Arizona
that's where I'm from
Arizona yeah Arizona
yeah I get it there's a lot of things
that just overall in general need to
improve on
yeah so what agree let me ask you a
question we're about to head out here
what's what's the games that you're
looking forward to this year
oh man um
you know first time I State the obvious
you know rarefall Starfield if hellblade
2 drops I'm definitely looking forward
to that
I'm looking forward to Spider-Man
um
Resident Evil 4. that's the next big
game I'm like I told you before attic I
never finished the game I played it when
it came to the PS2 played like halfway
through didn't finish it so I'm
definitely looking forward to that
um
I'm looking forward to the star Star
Wars Survivor I'm looking forward to
that and um yeah man um this is a pretty
big year for gaming I'm looking forward
to a lot of this stuff
yeah Star Wars Survivor I think is going
to do very well I'm hoping to get a
review code for that because I got a
little bit of a a connect over there and
we might may or may not be having uh
a developer on from respawn here soon
trailer story trailer drops tomorrow
I'm looking forward to that oh red fall
story trailer
yeah yeah there might be a lot of
information that's about to start
swarming these streets on redfall that's
all I'm willing to say on that end but
yeah man hey
um THX one one three eight with the two
says dirt are you based from New York
City always wearing beanies no I'm from
Detroit man
born and raised in Detroit yeah born and
raised in Detroit yeah so I am born from
Tucson Arizona and I moved uh on the
border between Virginia and West
Virginia and I've always like bounced
around some years I'll live in West
Virginia some years I live in Virginia
literally I can go 10 minutes down the
road and I will be in Virginia
and you know because I'm about to move
back into West Virginia and
I think that's
that's the biggest issue because I live
in a very heavy State and what's funny
is like people say I I don't have an
accent here
um
hold up uh
thx1338 oh yeah he asked you that if you
were born in uh in New York we got Mark
two six uh two zero six eight five
dollar super truck I want uh a here dirt
but I can't see him on my screen man
it's crazy that's crazy
you should have seen them in the chat
saying attic feels uncomfortable when
they were making those jokes
it was a good look man when they come in
the chair they they roast me make fun of
me and sean786 all day long
um but I know it's a lot of love man I
know a lot of love yeah so I because
people around here have an accent uh to
me but I they say I don't have an accent
right
but then when I go out to like New York
or stuff people say I have an accent
um
but
people in Tucson tell me I don't have an
accent so I think I've like my like
merged their accents together because I
I spent half of my you know younger life
in Tucson Arizona and half of my you
know teens and stuff in in in Virginia
and then I spent the majority of my
adulthood in Virginia so I think I've
merged these two things kind together a
little bit and it is what it is you know
I I do want to move because after you
start traveling and stuff Dirk because
I've been going a lot more events it
will go into packs next week
I realized I don't want to live two
hours away from an airport anymore
yeah yeah I live two hours from my
airport uh and it's such an
inconvenience because I have to find a
ride to the airport and
the airport is smaller uh where I
normally fly out of so that they can't
like hold on to my car or anything like
that so I have to like you know me and
me and uh my chick has to like work
around our schedules because she's going
to take me to the airport or my brother
has to take me to the airport and then
one of them got to come pick me up and
it's an hour and a half to two hour
drive yeah that's rough right there bro
and then and then not to mention when
you've traveled all day the last thing
you want to do is an hour and a half
drive home to two hours drive home so
I'm sitting there like
uh like just you know jet lagged a
little bit woke up mad early half a half
asleep but I'm like I got two literally
stay on this in this car for two hours
we gotta find out slippers from t h x
one one three eight you think Microsoft
landed on Starfield day in September was
about ABK merger final approval and
moving away from Diablo 4 release window
no I just think that's when the game was
ready what do you think though
um
I don't know when someone said sit down
on my podcast I said well it's very
interesting
um I guess I mean that could be the case
it could be what you said out of that is
needed those few more months
but I don't know man I think Xbox is
pretty confident that this deal is going
through though
I'll get that going through
oh the uh I'm right now I'm saying 90
10.
oh you real confident you might be more
confident than Microsoft is right now
yeah 9010 bro listen man they're bending
they're gone they're going above and
beyond to make sure all of the concerns
have been addressed of these regulators
all of their concerns have been
addressed the only people that you know
is still
listen it's at the point where if they
if the CMA block it
the Xbox is gonna fight man
like why are y'all blocking it you know
it's crazy so
that thing is definitely going through
yeah and I think this is one of those
scenarios where
we just got to be real with ourselves
you know we this is completely out of
our hands
I hope they didn't
change how something was going to work
just because of the potential that this
deal can go through or not I don't think
it's that I just think Starfield needed
to tell September and you know I think
we talked about it last week when it
comes to the Starfield release date
um you know if we didn't I give a brief
synapic what I said
I I care about Xbox's messaging I do but
I care about the health
and the games known as Starfield to do
good uh and to me you can only care
about one or the other now I feel like
you can criticize Xbox for their
messaging and encourage them not to be
doing this dumb messaging again but
don't rush out a game just because you
said you would rush out again
I agree always because I do dirt like I
feel like Star filled is one of the most
important games that they have launched
in a very long time it to this to this
degree
I think you could argue saying star
feels more important than Halo infinite
when it launched before it launched
because we knew what Halo infinite was
going to be like we knew what the kind
of gameplay that we might see from Halo
infinite we don't know nothing about
Starfield I feel like Starfield shows
about we were investing into these new
IPS we were investing into these
companies we're investing into these
Publishers and I feel like Starfield is
the first game this says this is why we
did it
um
you know addict I think Starfield is
I believe you said this before or
somebody said this before one of the
biggest
IP I think it means the most I believe
you might have said since the first Halo
imma say since gears
it's huge and I saw somebody on Twitter
say oh
when will Xbox be if they didn't have
zenimax that's a that's a stupid
question because that's the reason they
bought them
they bought them for content and they
are delivering this year is pretty much
but that's the year with the exception
of Force of Horizon
I'm sorry force of Motorsport and
potentially hellblade too
that's why they bought them
so they can develop games for them
you know it's crazy it's good people say
that and it's funny it's funny start
people say that because then I say where
would PlayStation be without Square Enix
even own them
or insomniac
yeah because it's on me I had a few
games from this generation they just
bought himself Nick not too long ago
yeah do you think the multiplayer games
that PlayStation gonna do you think
they're gonna hit do you think any of
them are gonna hit I don't know I feel
like I feel like those type of games are
hard to make a lot harder than companies
think and when they get into them they
realize the amount of work and the
amount of money now it's very profitable
you can make a lot of money doing it but
the thing is you have to have the
infrastructure right and you have to
have the game plan right and you have to
have the road map done and you have to
have a lot of community feedback to
build the game that the community wants
to play and a lot of people feel like
that's not a lot of work till they
actually do it
yeah and and you have to have some type
of originality with your game because
there's a lot of games as a service out
there listen I I believe the Naughty Dog
game will will cause a buzz because it's
Naughty Dog developing it
we don't know anything about Haven about
Valkyrie fire Sprite any of those other
teams
and we have to be honest about this
whole thing man um this is not going to
be the same PlayStation that people are
used to
yes they still want to have a Spider-Man
they probably still have some type of
God of War Game or something like that
but most of their games are going to be
games as a service man and people
they're living in the now they don't
want to admit it they are developing 10
games as a service
10 and I've always said this man I don't
know how you feel about this
if most of those turn out to be hit
because of like the influence and stuff
that that uh that that Bungie has with
all the information that Bungie has and
they know how people like content and
you know they got a lot of input they
can give that that took them years to
get and you know I'm not going to say
it's going to work for everyone but if a
couple of those take off and make good
money
I wouldn't be surprised if you start
seeing PlayStation you know not
necessarily cut funds towards the single
player stuff but they're like look we're
making we're making 500 million in a
month off this game and we made that off
the entire time that we did this game
you know so it's just like look like I
think that's a very
very
gray area for a lot of fans and you know
I'm not saying that it's the end of the
world Dirk but I am saying be very
cautious and I'm not saying wish those
games don't succeed but
I do think that that kind of money could
change someone now like from Starcraft
Elder and rain
you know there's a debate going on in
the from software Community where it's
like are they gonna go back to the old
routes of from software
or they're going to try to start making
more games like Eldon ring because they
seem good money but from software ain't
never seen that Elden ring money and
that changes people
and you write about that it's it's that
money of games as a service has changed
the entire industry sir in a lot of ways
for the bad
yeah yeah exactly because listen I I do
like some multiplayer games but I also
like some single player games listen I
said this the other day and I know we
gotta get out of here but um I believe
that Xbox has put themselves in a better
position with a service like Xbox game
pass where you can take more risk right
you can take more risks you know I don't
know if you saw the Tim Schaefer dice
interview where he was saying Xbox game
pass is great for them because they can
take more risk
some of their games are weird right
they're different style of games and he
says sometimes people would be in the
game store they wouldn't yeah this game
looks interesting but I don't think I
want to spend 70 for it but he said with
Xbox game pass they can just install it
they can download it and play it so
there's going to be games they're still
going to be single player games these
developers are able to take a chance
because of Xbox game pass meaning they
are putting themselves they put
themselves in the position for the
future
the company has done I'm okay with going
that direction but I think it's very
vital to
okay I would I would say I hate to use
the word charity but I think that's the
better word where it's like look we made
all this money from all these these
games as a service from you know games
like see see a thieves you know whatever
they have going on
to stop trying to incorporate those
those mechanics and those ways of making
money into everything else like for
instance fable
we made all this money from you know the
Halo franchise uh let's you know I mean
Halo infinite probably not the greatest
example but from Halo infinite to see
your thieves to let's say they get Call
of Duty from Call of Duty we can just
fund a single player only game maybe
some co-op features in it without trying
to bomb it would try with
microtransactions because we made so
much money off game pass off these other
avenues that we can fund this game and
not hurt us you know what I'm saying
yeah because I think that's the biggest
issue that I have is they make these
these single player games I mean these
uh these games as a service but when it
comes to their single player they try to
find
like unique ways of nickel and diming us
on those games too it's like no like
look I get it there's probably a lot of
money that that you're gonna eat but if
you made
10 billion dollars in 10 years and you
have to spend 500 million dollars on one
Fable game just spend the damn money you
know what I'm saying like make sure that
game does what it's supposed to because
I feel like that's one of the biggest
reasons that we're having people talk
about The Witcher no microtransactions
in it people talk about all of these mad
successful games Red Dead Redemption 2
besides the multiplayer to my knowledge
the single player has no no
microtransactions in it
um look at The Last of Us Part Two no
microtransactions in it people talk
about these Almighty games and one of
the reasons they do so well is because
they know they're a single player game
and they're not trying to push
microtransactions on you
um all right let's go ahead and start uh
heading out here man uh I I don't even
know why we got into that rant as a long
rant for no reason
that that was my fault that was my fault
um
one hour and we'll say 58 minutes is
when we started the outros no one really
cares about the outro timestamp but I'm
gonna put it in there anyway all right
don't work if people find GM and what
you got going on I know you got a lot of
things going on you better spam that
that link in the chat man you spam it
like 10 15 times I don't want to see
nothing in that shop with that link so
what where could people find you at
uh putting the link in the chat for
those that uh you know um
obviously I'm doing on my phone it's my
slower than when you do it
yeah so uh you know I haven't done a
video in a couple days we have uh last
WBZ Xbox podcast chip check it out it's
a pretty good show we was talking a lot
of trash
um so that's about it man um
yeah stop by and say what's up man have
a good old time
getting you know you could catch me
on IOP this week we actually have a lot
of stuff coming up I think you guys are
going to enjoy we have a pretty we have
an interesting guest this week I think
you guys enjoy that no it's not Phil
Spencer because I know it's the first
thing people in the chat is going to say
it feels like every day people expect
Phil Spencer to be on IOP every week
Philippines are coming on this week you
know what I will say
is we are working on it um I don't know
if it's gonna work but we are working on
it and if Carl told me to give you guys
the logistics on that if he didn't tell
me and I told you he'd kill me he'd kill
me but we all working on that you know
we got a pretty a lot of good stuff
going in for you guys right now uh we
will be at Pax next week
towards the trench coat at it he's
currently not here uh so we got a lot of
stuff that's going on I think you guys
will enjoy uh the content we're going to
cover you know we are going to PAX East
next week we're going to E3 in June I
think we might be going to Washington
for Pax West I don't know yet you know
there's been throwing words around like
Gamescom I doubt that's this year but it
does look like you know next year we we
are considering going to Gamescom it
just depends on what it happens because
you know
IOP makes a little bit of money
but not a lot and when you go on these
events with four people you eat through
that money very quickly
you know 700 each plane ticket three
thousand dollars for for hotels like it
it's ate up very very fast as but when
it comes like Gamescom that's a lot like
that's a lot I I don't even know how
much a plane ticket is from here to
Germany
but I know it ain't cheap right and
that's four people doing it
so you know in the place you got it you
got passports you have to get
because I can't just go to Germany
without a passport
so there's a lot of stuff going on uh
you know most likely we staying in the
States this year but next year we might
try to you know go out especially we're
getting more like sponsorships and stuff
so stuff like that would help pay for
stuff uh like going to to there so you
know I appreciate everyone for coming
through uh we add up to like 250 60
people in there you guys always show up
every week you know it's kind of like a
mixture between not having a lot to talk
about and just like I got up 15 minutes
before the show so I'm surprised that it
turned out as well as it did but you
know dirt's always there man Dirk
carries me man carried me all day all
week all year all month and I I
appreciate that but yeah definitely go
to dart's channel
his his link is in there like 15 times
so don't say you can't find it because
you're lying it's right there one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen times no reason
why you can't find
and uh we'll see you I don't know if
we'll have we will not have a show next
week because I will be at PAX East
uh so no show next week and uh we'll be
back
most likely we'll be back the following
week but I don't know it just depends on
how I feel coming back Sunday
because I might be jet glad for two days
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna send you
guys over there
to fame
and uh you know go over there to tell
them tell them
tell them to add addict sent you and you
know make sure to give them some love
manage I'll go over there and like that
video first off I don't want to see none
of your back next week until you like
his video so go over there and like it
tell them addicts that you can go listen
to listen to them carrier oh I got that
good good show man good show they
deserve more viewership and uh this is
Lord addict and Dirk greggedy and we are
out see ya see you in two weeks peace
out